Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History and our second episode on the history of disease when we're joined by the University of Oklahoma's magisterial Professor Kyle Harper. So Kyle, if we can jump on a couple of centuries from where we were before but also kind of back to something you alluded to earlier the colombian exchange which is this absolute extraordinary moment in world history when you know columbus um arrives first of all in the caribbean then you have the arrival of the conquistadors in in mexico and peru the classic stories that you know tom you and i would have read as pure adventure stories when we were
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听特权，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收看《The Rest Is History》，这是我们关于疾病史的第二期节目，今天做客节目的嘉宾是来自俄克拉荷马大学的权威学者凯尔·哈珀教授。那么凯尔，如果我们把时间从刚才讲到的那个时期往后推进几个世纪，同时也回到你之前提到过的一个话题——哥伦布大交换，这是世界历史上一个绝对非凡的时刻，当时，你知道，哥伦布先是抵达了加勒比海，然后征服者们抵达了墨西哥和秘鲁，这些经典故事，你知道，汤姆，你和我小时候
growing up as as boys and there was virtually no mention of it at all i would have read as pure adventure stories when we were growing up as boys. And there was virtually no mention of it at all, I would have said, in the kind of children's histories of the subsequent kind of death toll. So what's the thinking now? Because you, I mean, obviously there is a colossal death toll, but it's not as cataclysmic as is often thought. And what are the diseases that the Europeans are bringing?
作为男孩长大时读过的，几乎完全没有提到过它，作为男孩长大时读过的。而且我可以说，在后来的儿童历史书中，几乎完全没有提到过随之而来的巨大死亡人数。那么现在人们是怎么看的呢？因为，我的意思是，显然有巨大的死亡人数，但它并不像人们通常认为的那样毁灭性。那么欧洲人带来的疾病到底是什么？
And also crucially i suppose you know obviously an exchange implies a two-way process so how is it that the the the indigenous americans as it were are dying in such large numbers but not the europeans or are the europeans dying and we just don't talk about it? Yeah, well, those are all great questions. And I'd say there was a tendency in the maybe 60s, 70s, 80s among scholars to exaggerate the population of the New World and to say there were 100, 120 million people in the Americas at the time of European arrival. That now seems, in general, probably implausible. The real number, we don't know, but it's probably closer to 40 million, give or take 10 million, than it is triple that number. The proposition that there were 100 and something million people in the Americas at the time of the New World sort of required that the arrival of, say, smallpox just sort of swept over the entire continent or both continents without before the Europeans could even get there in person in many cases.
而且同样关键的是，我想，显然“交换”意味着一个双向的过程，所以为什么美洲原住民会以如此庞大的数量死去，而欧洲人却没有？还是说其实欧洲人也死了，只是我们不说？是的，这些都是很好的问题。我想说的是，在60、70、80年代的学者中，有一种倾向，他们会夸大新世界的人口，并声称在欧洲人到达时，美洲有1亿到1.2亿人。现在看来，总的来说这可能不太可信。真实的数字我们不得而知，但它可能更接近4000万，误差在1000万左右，而不是那个数字的三倍。那种认为新世界发现时美洲有1亿多人的说法，在某种程度上要求天花之类的疾病在欧洲人甚至还没来得及亲自到达的许多地方，就直接席卷了整个大陆或两个大陆。
And I think that version of the story has really suffered from a close look. But with that said, I still think that we can overdo that historiographical correction. So we can be too critical of that story and sort of forget that the biology matters. You say about, so we talked about the
我认为这种版本的历史叙事在经过仔细审视后确实受到了很大冲击。但话虽如此，我仍然认为我们不能过度进行这种史学上的修正。所以我们不能对那个故事过于批判，以至于忘记了生物学因素的重要性。你提到关于，所以我们谈到了
conquistadors and cortez arriving in um the aztec empire the the demographic crash of mexico in the 16th century is one of the most extreme demographic events attested in history in 1516 there were perhaps 8 to 10 million inhabitants there by the end of the century there were two to three million but that might not just be because of disease though tom that might be because of the collapse of agriculture or disruption or war or all these or famine or all these other things, right? But it's clearly all of it. And it's only a question of in what proportion and through what mechanisms. I mean, there was a massive smallpox pandemic in 1520, 1521 that must kill a tragic number of people. There's another disease outbreak in the 1540s
征服者和科尔特斯抵达阿兹特克帝国的情况，16世纪墨西哥的人口崩溃是历史上最极端的人口事件之一。1516年，那里可能还有800万到1000万居民，到了本世纪末，只剩下200万到300万。但汤姆，这可能不仅仅是因为疾病，这可能还因为农业的崩溃、社会动荡、战争，或者所有这些，或者饥荒，或者所有这些其他因素，对吧？但这显然是所有这些因素共同作用的结果。问题只在于各自的比例是多少，以及通过什么机制。我的意思是，1520年到1521年爆发了一场大规模的天花大流行，夺去了悲剧般大量的生命。1540年代又爆发了一场疾病，
that is extremely well attested in the evidentiary record. We don't totally know what it was, and it may have been multiple diseases. This is also one really cool area where the ancient DNA, there was a team that sequenced the DNA of the pathogen that killed a victim, several victims from skeletons at a site in South Central Mexico in the 1540s. And what they found was paratyphoid fever. So it wasn't smallpox, which doesn't mean smallpox wasn't there. It wasn't typhus, which doesn't mean typhus wasn't there. But what they did find in a number of these mass burial skeletal remains was a bacterial pathogen that is transmitted via the fecal-oral route. So a disease that is transmitted in waste that would have been introduced from Europe, from the old world. And this is a really interesting find, unexpected find.
在证据记录中得到了极其充分的证实。我们并不完全清楚那是什么病，它可能是多种疾病。这也是一个非常酷的领域，古代DNA方面，曾有一个团队对墨西哥中南部一个遗址中1540年代的几具骨骼遗骸（某种疾病受害者）的病原体DNA进行了测序。他们发现的是副伤寒。所以它不是天花，这并不意味着当时没有天花。它也不是斑疹伤寒，这并不意味着当时没有斑疹伤寒。但他们在许多这样的集体埋葬骨骼遗骸中确实发现了一种通过粪口传播的细菌病原体。也就是说，这种疾病是通过排泄物传播的，是从欧洲、从旧世界引入的。这是一个非常有趣的发现，也是一个意想不到的发现。
And it does remind us that it wasn't just these big notorious diseases like smallpox, but it's the total biological change, the introduction of a large number of pathogens that would have been unfamiliar in the new world. So that's a really good example. But 1540s, then again, a generation later, and then again, about a decade later. So there's these four really big pandemics that strike one of the most densely settled corridors of the new world in central Mexico, and really did have cumulatively a major, major demographic effect. that apparently it was in the New World before Columbus arrived there. So it originates in East Africa. It spreads. And seals seem to have caught it.
这也提醒我们，引发灾难的不只是天花这样声名狼藉的大病，而是整体生物环境的改变，是大量对新世界而言完全陌生的病原体的引入。所以这是一个非常好的例子。接着是1540年代，然后又过了一代人，接着大约又过了一个十年。因此，在墨西哥中部这个新世界人口最密集的走廊之一，连续爆发了四次非常大的流行病，累积起来确实产生了重大而深远的人口影响。显然它在哥伦布到达之前就已经存在于新世界了。所以它起源于东非。它传播开来。海豹似乎感染了它。
And they seem to have swum across the Atlantic and then been butchered and eaten. And this is the crazy story that seems to be the way that the dots are connected as far as we know now. And it may change as archaeogeneticists get more DNA, but tuberculosis is, we can talk about it, is one of the great human diseases by any measure.
它们似乎游过了大西洋，然后被宰杀并食用。这就是那个疯狂的故事，据我们目前所知，这些线索似乎就是这样连结在一起的。随着古遗传学家获得更多DNA，这种情况可能会改变，但无论从哪个标准来看，结核病都是人类历史上最重大的疾病之一，我们可以好好聊聊它。
It's a chronic respiratory disease. It's a very strange disease and it causes a huge burden of morbidity and mortality. One of the big mysteries was that tuberculosis, the people who work on skeletons, archaeologists who work on New World skeletons, really believed that tuberculosis was there. And one of the things about tuberculosis, because it's a chronic disease, it can leave a mark on the skeleton. Most of these acute infectious diseases, so like plague or smallpox, they kill you so quickly, they don't leave evidence in your skeleton. But chronic infectious diseases like
这是一种慢性的呼吸系统疾病。这是一种非常奇怪的疾病，它带来了沉重的发病率和死亡率负担。最大的谜团之一是，结核病——那些研究骨骼的人，即研究新世界骨骼的考古学家——真的相信结核病当时就在那里。关于结核病的一个特点是，由于它是一种慢性病，它会在骨骼上留下痕迹。大多数急性传染病，比如瘟疫或天花，夺命太快，它们不会在你的骨骼中留下证据。但慢性传染病，比如
leprosy, tuberculosis, syphilis can produce very diagnostic stresses in skeletal remains. And so the people who worked on the neural burns were saying tuberculosis was here. And if you were looking at the record, the historical record, there were various reasons to think that that was maybe not the case. Certainly when we started getting genetics, all of the new world tuberculosis today is descended from European tuberculosis. So this caused a real dissonance. And the way it seems to be resolved at the moment is that there was, so there was tuberculosis here before Columbus, the DNA has been found. What's interesting about the lineage of the DNA of tuberculosis in the new world prior to European arrival is that it seems to be very closely related to and descended from a branch of the bacterial family tree that is commonly found in
麻风病、结核病、梅毒，会在骨骼遗骸中产生非常具有诊断意义的压力痕迹。因此，那些研究新世界遗骸的人说，结核病当时就在这里。而如果你查看历史记录，有各种各样的理由认为事实可能并非如此。当然，当我们开始获得基因数据时，如今所有新世界的结核病都源自欧洲的结核病。这就造成了一种真正的认知不和谐。目前看来，这种矛盾的解决方式是：在哥伦布到达之前，这里确实存在结核病，其DNA已经被找到了。关于欧洲人到来之前新世界结核病DNA谱系，有趣的是，它似乎与细菌家族树中常见于以下生物的分支有着极紧密的亲缘关系，并且是其后代：
sea mammals. So this suggests the possibility that this ultimately human disease is going from humans into other animals. So tuberculosis is a human disease as we know it, but it also infects other animals. And it's possible that humans, either directly or through some other intermediate animals, gave it to sea mammals who have helped disperse it to places across oceans even before humans could move. So it's a pretty wild story that the puzzle pieces certainly can be fit together that way. And it has resolved this big problem that there's tuberculosis in the new world before Columbus, you can see it in the bones. But when European tuberculosis arrives, it sort of outcompetes the local strains that don't exist anymore. Can I ask a question? We had questions sent in by our listeners. Tom and I frequently
海洋哺乳动物。这就暗示了一种可能性：这种最终成为人类疾病的病原体，是从人类传播给其他动物的。所以，就我们所知，结核病是一种人类疾病，但它也会感染其他动物。人类有可能直接或通过其他中间动物，将它传染给了海洋哺乳动物，而海洋哺乳动物又帮助它在人类能够跨越海洋之前，就将其扩散到了各大洋的各个地方。所以这是一个相当离奇的故事，各种拼图碎片确实可以这样拼凑在一起。这就解决了这个大难题：为什么在哥伦布到达之前新世界就存在结核病，你甚至能在骨头上看到它。但当欧洲的结核病到来时，它在竞争中胜过了当地的菌株，导致后者不复存在。我可以问个问题吗？我们的听众发来了很多问题。汤姆和我经常
fail to ask any of the questions that the listeners have sent in by our listeners we haven't we've tom and i frequently i fail to ask any of the the questions that the listeners have sent in so we should ask them in fairness so we should ask while you're very kind so um a couple of them sent in questions about divine punishment so um joshua terry sw jacobs they both said at what point do people stop seeing diseases divine punishment so with the black death is a is a great example isn't it because there were lots of people at the time who said we have been punished for our sins by god and obviously over time that dwindles but at what point do you think i mean early modern what's the point or or or later you know 18th century
忘了问听众们发来的任何问题。汤姆和我经常忘了问听众发来的任何问题，所以为了公平起见，我们应该问问。既然你这么客气，那么……他们中有几个人提出了关于神圣惩罚的问题——比如约瑟夫·泰瑞、S.W.雅各布斯，他们都提到：人们在什么时候才会不再将疾病视为神圣的惩罚？所以，黑死病就是一个很好的例子，对吧？因为当时有很多人说，我们是因为犯了罪而遭到上帝的惩罚。当然，随着时间的推移，这种观念逐渐减弱，但你认为是在什么时候——比如近代早期，或者更晚的18世纪、
victorian what's the point in which people stop looking, as it were, to the heavens for the causes? Yeah, well, I mean, and obviously, it never completely stops, right? Think of some of the responses to AIDS or even COVID-19. So it doesn't completely stop, but the point of the question is a good one. And the way I would get to the real answer, I think, is the 18th century. And I think there's a really
维多利亚时代——人们是在哪个时间点不再从上天那里寻找疾病的原因的呢？是的，我的意思是，很显然，这种观念从未完全消失，对吧？想想人们对艾滋病或甚至是新冠肺炎的一些反应就知道了。所以它并没有完全消失，但这个问题的切入点很好。我认为，要找到真正的答案，时间应该指向18世纪。我认为在科学文化中有一个非常
seminal moment in the culture of science, and that includes medical science, where, of course, there's rational medical science going back to antiquity. And yet, in the 18th century, there becomes a much more pervasive, one, empirical mindset. So it's sort of part of the triumph of, of, of let's not trust dogma, whether that's religious dogma or received, you know, Hippocratic, Galenic medicine, we have to test everything. And look at, look at, you know, one of, I think the great accomplishments of the human mind is Edward Jenner's 1798 publication of the discovery of vaccination. It is a perfect reflection of 18th century empiricism in that it's very undogmatic. I mean, he doesn't really have a theory of why vaccination works. He sort of
具有开创性的时刻，其中也包括医学科学。当然，理性的医学科学可以追溯到古代。然而在18世纪，一种更具普遍性的、实证主义的心态开始占据主导。所以这可以说是打破教条的胜利的一部分，无论这种教条是宗教教条，还是承袭自古代的希波克拉底或盖伦医学，我们必须对一切进行检验。你看，我认为人类心灵最伟大的成就之一，就是爱德华·詹纳在1798年发表的关于发现牛痘疫苗的著作。它完美地反映了18世纪的经验主义，因为它非常不教条。我的意思是，他其实并没有一套关于为什么接种疫苗会起作用的理论。他某种程度上
is interested in connections between animal and human health and disease, obviously. But it's a series of case studies. I mean, you know, his proposition, his hypothesis about vaccination is only going to stand or fall on the empirical record. It's a really cool, it's an amazing accomplishment, but it's to me a kind of symbol of the empirical mindset. But also combined with that is a kind of optimism that infectious disease can be prevented. And they don't think of it as infectious disease even, just that a large number of human diseases, before they even understand germs, microbiology really is
当然是对动物和人类健康与疾病之间的联系感兴趣。但这其实是一系列案例研究。我的意思是，你知道的，他关于疫苗接种的命题和假设，只能由经验证据来支持或推翻。这真的很酷，是一个了不起的成就，但在我看来，它是一种经验主义心态的象征。但除此之外，还伴随着一种乐观主义，即传染病是可以被预防的。他们甚至不认为这是传染病，只是觉得在他们甚至还不懂病原体、微生物学真的是
the key to understanding the mechanisms of disease. There's a sense that human societies and human individuals can do things. They can wash their clothes. They can avoid really closed indoor environments where the air is congested and dirty. They don't understand that tuberculosis is spread in tiny little droplets that carry the bacterium from one person to the next. But if you say we can prevent disease by making sure that there's good ventilation and access to clean water and that we're draining swamps so that they have the mechanism totally wrong of what causes malaria or what they call the ague. But if they say we can stop it by draining this swamp, they don't know that it's killing the mosquitoes that are transmitting the disease, but it works. So on the topic of insects and transmission, you have, I thought, a completely devastating chapter, basically, on the impact that the slave trade has on the spread of diseases from this kind of great sink of disease in West Africa to the tropics in the new world. And you describe Ailes aegypti, mosquito, as the most dangerous animal in the world because it takes yellow fever to the character Jamaica, to Barbados, islands that had been covered in jungle that have then been felled, sugarcane planted. And what this insect needs is sugar, human bodies, and stationary water.
理解疾病机制的关键之前，有大量的人类疾病，人们觉得人类社会和个人是可以做些事情的。他们可以洗衣服。他们可以避免待在空气混浊污浊的封闭室内环境中。他们并不了解结核病是通过携带细菌的微小飞沫从一个人传给另一个人的。但如果你说，我们可以通过确保良好的通风、获得干净的水、排干沼泽来预防疾病——尽管他们对导致疟疾（或者他们当时称为“打摆子”的病）的机制完全搞错了——但如果他们说排干这个沼泽就能阻止它，他们虽然不知道这杀死了传播疾病的蚊子，但它确实管用。所以，说到昆虫和传播，我发现你书中有一个可以说是颠覆性的章节，主要讲的是奴隶贸易对疾病传播的影响，把疾病从西非这个巨大的疾病汇集地带到了新世界的炎热地带。你将埃及伊蚊描述为世界上最危险的动物，因为它将黄金热（黄金热应为黄热病）带到了牙买加、巴巴多斯——这些原本被丛林覆盖、随后被砍伐并种植甘蔗的岛屿。而这种昆虫需要的是糖分、人体和静止的水。
And on the slave plantations, you have all three. Obviously, we think of slavery as a plague, but I had not realized that it kind of literally serves to incubate plague as well and disease. And is this something that is widely appreciated because i had i had i hadn't appreciated at all i read your chapter well i thank you i i think it's so important and i think it has been too often missing from big histories of disease for whatever reason now there's there's some very good work. And in particular, I'm indebted to the work of John McNeill, whose book Mosquito Empires is an amazing contribution to
在奴隶种植园里，这三样东西全都有。显然，我们认为奴隶制本身就是一场瘟疫，但我以前没有意识到它实际上也在字面意义上起到了孕育瘟疫和疾病的温床的作用。这是一个广为人知的观点吗？因为我以前完全没有意识到这一点，直到我读了你的章节。嗯，谢谢你，我认为这非常重要。不知为什么，在以往宏大的疾病史著作中，这一块往往被忽略了。现在有了一些非常优秀的研究。特别是，我要感谢约翰·麦克尼尔（John McNeill）的著作，他的书《蚊子帝国》（Mosquito Empires）为
understanding these diseases. But for whatever reason, the histories as they've been written, they've been, I think, very Eurocentric and focused on what diseases Europeans are carrying, like smallpox or typhus, which we don't really know where that comes from. But there's been not nearly the same amount of interest or attention on the introduction of tropical diseases from the old world to the new world. And this has a huge effect on the kinds of societies that take shape in the Americas. And the kinds of societies that take shape in the Americas influence the diseases, how they move and how they fare in the Americas. So exactly as you were describing, the creation of a sugar plantation regime
理解这些疾病做出了惊人的贡献。但无论出于什么原因，以往写就的历史往往非常欧洲中心主义，只关注欧洲人携带的疾病，比如天花或斑疹伤寒——我们甚至不确定斑疹伤寒究竟源自哪里。然而，人们对于将热带疾病从旧世界引入新世界的关注和兴趣却远远不够。这对美洲最终形成的社会类型产生了巨大的影响。而美洲形成的社会类型又反过来影响了疾病，决定了它们如何在美洲传播和立足。所以，正如你刚才所描述的，甘蔗种植园制度的建立
creates the ecological context where- Because they're death traps, basically, aren't they? They're death traps, basically, aren't they? some of the, probably the worst sustained mortality rates in any sort of large scale context in human history. And so I think we have to reckon with what are the environmental dimensions of that? What are the specific diseases? And you mentioned yellow fever and malaria. Those are probably the two biggest ones, but there are others like hookworm and yaws that are also part of the story and kind of get left out sometimes. But that dimension of the whole Colombian exchange and making sure that it's not just what Europe brings to the Americas, but also is this triangular movement between Europe,
创造了一种生态环境，使得——因为它们基本上就是死亡陷阱，对吧？它们基本上就是死亡陷阱，对吧？这里维持着人类历史上任何大规模情境下最糟糕的持续死亡率。所以我觉得我们必须正视其背后的环境维度是什么？具体的疾病有哪些？你提到了黄热病和疟疾。这可能是其中最大的两种，但还有钩虫病和雅司病等其他疾病也是这段历史的一部分，有时却被遗漏了。哥伦布大交换的这个维度，确保了我们不能只看到欧洲带给美洲的东西，还要看到欧洲、
Africa, and the new world. Because that also affects the kind of societies that grow up in. So you meant to talk about West Africa, for example. Europeans don't settle in West Africa, obviously, because it's notoriously dangerous. I mean, you'll die of disease, you know, a posting to a West African kind of fort or something or a trading station can often be a death sentence, right? Yeah. I mean, I think it's certainly one of the factors for why there's not direct European colonization of West Africa. It's simply that the disease regime, first and foremost, the effect of malaria, falciparum malaria, the worst form of malaria, imposes such a heavy burden of mortality that
非洲和新世界之间的这种三角运动。因为这也影响了当地滋生的社会形态。比如你刚才提到西非。欧洲人显然不在西非定居，因为那里出了名的危险。我的意思是，你会死于疾病，被派往西非的某种堡垒或贸易站往往就等于被判了死刑，对吧？是的。我的意思是，我认为这绝对是欧洲人没有直接对西非进行殖民的原因之一。很简单，那里的疾病环境——首先也是最重要的，恶性疟疾（最致命的疟疾）的影响——带来了如此沉重的死亡负担，
it's not even really a possibility until the 19th century with advances in medicine and weaponry at the same time. So the European mortality rates that are involved in the West African trade that we can sort of piece together are so astonishingly high. You just sort of wonder how did this even, how did they convince people to even be willing to take part in it? It was deceit, desperation, greed, but it's still just astonishing how deadly it was to encounter some of the environments of malaria that they were exposed to. We talked all about sugar. Is it a different story on cotton plantations in the American South? Is the mortality rate from disease lower there? Yeah. I mean, this is something I can only kind of superficially get into in the book because
以至于在19世纪医学和武器同时取得进步之前，这种殖民根本是不可能的。因此，我们可以拼凑出的参与西非贸易的欧洲人死亡率是如此惊人地高，你简直会好奇，他们当时到底是怎么说服人们愿意参与其中的？其中有欺骗、绝望、贪婪，但遭遇他们所暴露的疟疾环境时，其致死率之高依然令人震惊。我们聊了很多关于糖的事情。美国南方的棉花种植园情况是否有所不同？那里的疾病死亡率较低吗？是的。我的意思是，这只能算是我在书中比较浅尝辄止的一个话题，因为
trying to move across so much time and space, but it's clearly, when you're thinking about disease, you're always talking about the total ecological context. You know, what's being grown? What are the soils like? And there's a huge variety as you, even within the Caribbean, but as you move into the, say, the U.S. South, obviously the unhealthiest regions of the South are like the Mississippi Delta and the really deep South. New Orleans, probably one of the most unhealthy places in North America. It's really the only place where yellow fever can can basically be endemic um virtually all the time um and then there's a
要在如此宏大的时空中穿梭很难深入展开，但很显然，当你思考疾病时，你永远是在讨论整体的生态环境。你知道，种植的是什么？土壤是什么样的？正如你所知，即使在加勒比海内部也有巨大的差异，但当你进入美国南方时，显然南方最不健康的地区是密西西比三角洲和南方腹地。新奥尔良可能是北美最不健康的地方之一。它基本上是唯一一个黄热病几乎可以随时风土化（地方性流行）的地方，
huge difference again as you move into like the tidewater atlantic um and differences even between like south carolina um and the the mid-atlanticantic, where the plantation environments, the soils, crops, crop regimes, agricultural regimes, the social systems that those require, as well as the mosquitoes, what disease vectors and what diseases can exist are all interconnected. And the diseases are part of that story. But the line, and then even as you move further north, the Mason-Dixon line in the U.S. from really the south to the north along the Atlantic, which is sort of the transitional zone also where slavery moves from becoming a really absolutely dominant social institution to a kind of increasingly marginal one is also a really
然后，当你向大西洋沿岸低地移动时，情况又大不相同了，甚至南卡罗来纳州和大西洋中部的环境也存在差异，那里的种植园环境、土壤、农作物、作物制度、农业制度、它们所需的社会系统，以及蚊子、存在哪些疾病媒介和哪些疾病，都是相互关联的。疾病就是这个故事的一部分。而且，甚至当你向更北移动时，美国从南到北沿大西洋的梅森-迪克森线（这也是奴隶制从一个绝对占据统治地位的社会制度过渡为一个日益边缘化的制度的过渡地带），也是疾病生态学中一个非常
important disease gradient in the in the ecology of disease and so you don't really have falciparum malaria above the the mid-atlantic ever in the in the united states whereas you do have it in say south carolina and that's a huge huge ingredient that's really important part of the story and if you look at the history of colonialism european colonialism and i guess specifically british colonialism um the the settler colonies whether it's new england in the 17th century or um australia or canada these are it's not a coincidence that these are areas that are essentially kind of immune to yellow fever and malaria and all the kind of diseases that otherwise would would prevent settler communities from establishing themselves yeah it is and it's
重要的疾病梯度。所以在美国，你在大西洋中部以北基本不会遇到恶性疟疾，但在南卡罗来纳州却能遇到，这是一个极其重要的因素，是故事中非常关键的一部分。如果你看看殖民主义的历史，特别是英国殖民主义的历史，无论是17世纪的新英格兰、澳大利亚还是加拿大，这些地方基本上对黄热病、疟疾以及其他会阻碍定居者社区建立的各种疾病免疫，这绝非巧合。是的，确实如此，而且
it's interesting to the the mentality um of of colonialism doesn't um doesn't really think in those terms. And, you know, one example of this is in the 1760s when it's obvious that the British are on the verge of defeating the French and preparing for treaty talks. There was a huge discussion in Britain about whether the Brits should demand Canada, like all of Canada or Guadalupe, you know, this tiny Caribbean island. And it was the fact that it was even sort of a major and, you know, intensely felt debate. Do you want what we would know, you know, just thinking of it in crass economic terms, a region of vast natural resources and hugely expansive land surface or a sugar island. And there are a lot of people who said we should demand this French sugar island because it was so valuable
殖民主义的心态也很有趣，它其实并不是从这些角度去思考的。一个例子是1760年代，当时很明显英国即将击败法国并准备进行和平谈判。英国国内曾有过一场巨大的争论，讨论英国究竟应该要求获得加拿大——比如整个加拿大，还是瓜德罗普——你知道的，加勒比海的一个小岛。当时这甚至成了一场重大且备受关注的辩论。你是想要我们现在所知的、仅从粗陋的经济角度来考虑的拥有广阔自然资源和巨大土地面积的地区，还是想要一个产糖的小岛？当时有很多人说，我们应该要求得到这个法国产糖岛，因为它在
in terms of the 18th century economy. Let's take a quick break here. We'll see you in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's theentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. So going into the 19th century, this is when people start to,
18世纪的经济中太有价值了。我们在这里稍事休息。几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德，我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处；在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐产业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 theentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。那么进入19世纪，这个时候人们开始，
certainly in Britain, and I guess in the United States as well, and in West European cities, there's massive projects to reform public health. There's a kind of understanding that basically living in your own shit isn't good, and that dumping it in rivers isn't good. But that is still, the assumption is still that there are kind of things like miasmas that drift around. And you say in your book that the concept of the miasma, the idea that germs kind of drift along on the air, it's wrong, but it's creatively wrong because it generates these campaigns to reform toxic cities. Yeah, exactly. I mean, miasma theory, the idea that sort of different kinds of environmental corruption or pollution in the atmosphere, putrefying matter, so it's something you can smell, is a source of disease. to be wrong because it doesn't really posit the existence of microbiological agents that infect the body.
当然是在英国，我猜在美国以及西欧城市也是如此，出现了大规模改造公共卫生的项目。人们开始有一种共识，即基本上生活在自己的排泄物里是不好的，把排泄物倒入河里是不好的。但这仍然——这种假设仍然是，空气中会漂浮着诸如瘴气之类的东西。你在书中提到，瘴气这个概念——即病菌随空气漂移的观点——虽然是错的，但它是一种具有建设性的错误，因为它催生了改造有毒城市的运动。是的，完全如此。我的意思是，瘴气理论认为，环境中各种腐败或污染的大气、腐烂的物质（也就是你能闻到的气味）是疾病的来源。
But it may steer you towards doing some things that nevertheless work. And again, I mentioned, you know, Jenner doesn't even know how vaccination works. There's similar parallels in terms of some of the public health movements towards sewage and clean water. And in the context of the early 19th century, you have rapid industrialization, rapid urbanization, all of which is sort of, in some ways, setting back human health. Well, again, skeletons start to shrink, don't they?
从科学上讲它是错的，因为它并没有假设那些感染人体的微生物病原体的存在。
They do, yeah. You see that it's a paradox. You see both very clearly in Western Europe and the United States. In the United States, it's called the Antebellum Paradox, that we know there's economic growth and urbanization and trade and manufacturers and finance are expanding, but also people are getting shorter. And the reason is because of the challenges of living in urban settlements. And one thing this does is it spurs the rise of a public health movement. So it kind of the sanitarian movement, the galvanization of a political force that starts to agitate. And this has a multi takes different shape in different societies as multiple facets. There's a social justice element to it that says, look, urbanization is making people very, very poor and desperate laborers. So there's really political dimensions to this.
但它可能会引导你去做一些同样管用的事情。再次强调，正如我所提到的，詹纳甚至不知道疫苗接种是如何起作用的。在针对污水和清洁水的公共卫生运动中，也有类似的情况。在19世纪早期的背景下，你经历了快速的工业化和快速的城市化，在某种程度上，所有这些都在阻碍人类健康。你看，人们的身高又开始缩水了，对吧？确实如此。你会发现这是一个悖论。在西欧和美国，你都能非常清楚地看到这一点。在美国，这被称为“内战前悖论”，我们知道经济在增长、城市化在推进、贸易、制造业和金融业在扩张，但与此同时人们却在变矮。原因就在于城市定居生活带来的种种挑战。而这产生的一个影响就是促成了公共卫生运动的兴起。所以这有点像卫生改良运动，一种开始进行鼓动的政治力量的凝聚。这在不同的社会中呈现出不同的形态，具有多个方面。其中包含社会正义的元素，人们指出，城市化让人们变得非常非常穷，成为了绝望的劳动力。所以这其中确实有着深刻的政治维度。
But they're on the track of saying we have to clean up the cities. And is that turbocharged by the emergence of the new disease of cholera, which I hadn't realized. I mean, basically it emerges, you say, in August 1817, 50 miles from Calcutta, which seems very precise. Origination point. It's cholera is in some ways one of the most revealing diseases of the 19th century, particularly from a global perspective. And I think, first of all, you have to look at it from a global perspective. It's a major disease, still a major disease.
但他们的方向是正确的，那就是我们必须清洁城市。而这种努力是否被一种新疾病——霍乱的出现给按下了加速键？我以前没有意识到这一点。我的意思是，基本上它出现了，正如你所说，在1817年8月，距离加尔各答50英里处，这似乎非常精确。这是它的起源点。霍乱在某种程度上是19世纪最具启示性的疾病之一，特别是从全球视角来看。我认为，首先你必须从全球视角来看待它。这是一种重大疾病，至今仍是一种重大疾病。
It's a terrifying disease when it's fecal-oral transmission. So you get it from poop getting into the digestive tract of the next victim, it causes very severe and rapid dehydration. So it can kill you within a day of infection, which is pretty extraordinary. And it really is a product of globalization. We now know that cholera isn't an ancient disease. It may have existed before 1817 um but not for for all that long um and and that really is the moment when it becomes a global disease it reaches calcutta it
当它通过粪口传播时，这是一种可怕的疾病。所以你是通过粪便进入下一个受害者的消化道而感染的，它会导致非常严重且迅速的脱水。因此它可以在感染后的一天内致死，这是相当了不起的。它确实是全球化的产物。我们现在知道，霍乱并不是一种古老的疾病。它可能在1817年之前就存在过，
reaches the the shipping networks of yeah because because it's next to calcutta which is the capital of british india and british exactly so then it goes out into the world and it goes out into the world again and again we see that and the first wave doesn't quite make it to Western Europe, but it's terrifying. But then in 1832, it does. It reaches Europe and the United States. And it's a disease that's interesting in that it doesn't actually kill anything like the number of people that plague or soon influenza will in Western Europe. But it really, it scares the heck out of society because it's at a time when there'd already been really important progress against
但存在的时间并不算太长。而那确实是它成为一种全球性疾病的时刻，它到达了加尔各答，
in controlling epidemic disease. So the really violent plagues, mortality shocks, mostly caused by Yersinia pestis had sort of been brought under control in Western Europe. Most people still died of infectious disease, but they died of tuberculosis and typhoid and sort of constant endemic diseases. And cholera was partly terrifying because it killed you so quickly and was so ghastly violent in its course.
进入了航运网络。是的，因为它靠近加尔各答——英属印度的首都，英国的领地——所以它就这样传播到了世界各地，一次又一次地向世界扩散，我们都看到了这一点。第一波疫情并没有完全传到西欧，但它非常可怕。然而到了1832年，它真的传到了。它到达了欧洲和美国。这种疾病有趣的地方在于，它造成的死亡人数其实远不及瘟疫或不久后流感在西欧造成的死亡人数。但它确实把社会吓坏了，因为它发生在一个人类已经在
But it was also terrifying because it was clearly causing these major epidemics at a time when Europe had just sort of started to get those under control, and it threatened to undo that. Just to ask on the impact that cholera has, it's also a disease of the poor, right? Because the poor are likelier to having filthy water. And so in a sense, that kind of amplifies social justice movements. It cuts across all kinds of political divides and issues, exactly. Let's talk about another globalized disease, if you like,
控制流行病方面取得了非常重要进展的时期。因此，那些主要由鼠疫耶尔森菌引起的极其猛烈的瘟疫和死亡冲击，在西欧当时已经基本得到了控制。大多数人仍然死于传染病，但他们死于结核病、伤寒以及那些持续存在的地方性疾病。而霍乱之所以令人恐惧，一部分是因为它夺命极快，其病程极其残暴猛烈；
or another pandemic. So this is the one with which most listeners will, I guess, automatically be familiar because it's the one we've heard most about since the arrival of COVID-19, which is the so-called Spanish flu. So we know that the Spanish um was around in the great allied kind of troop camps at a tap there is some suggestion that it might have come from the american midwest and been brought by uh i mean i as far as i know the jury is kind of out on that but but maybe you know better but do you think there are well what are the what are the other
但它同样可怕的原因在于，正当欧洲刚刚开始将这些流行病控制住的时候，它却显然引发了这些大规模的疫情，并且威胁着要将之前的成果毁于一旦。顺便问一下霍乱的影响，它也是一种穷人的疾病，对吧？因为穷人更有可能接触到肮脏的水源。所以在某种程度上，这起到了放大社会正义运动的作用。它跨越了各种政治分歧和议题，确实如此。我们来谈谈另一种全球化的疾病，如果你愿意这样称呼的话，
lessons we can learn from the spanish flu are there are there particularly resonant parallels between you know the 1918-19 situation and 2020-21 or or are they completely different do you think well like a good academic i'll say yes and no of course and the jury is out um i think it we don't really know that it came from the American Midwest. The better, more recent work suggests it was everywhere at once by the time we really see it. And we don't, it's a virus, it's a viral disease whose virus is normally endemic in bird populations. It's one of the kind of unusual, the most rare diseases are mammal diseases. This is a, this is a bird disease, which is kind of not totally unique, but it's, it's a little bit weird and influenza evolves in very different ways from COVID-19. So it has a segmented genome. It's kind of like a genome that exists in these eight mix and match parts. And this is like the H1N1 are describing the proteins for they're coded for by these different parts. And so the viral genome gets inside a host cell. And when it reassembles,
或者说另一场大流行。这就是大多数听众可能最熟悉的，因为自从新冠疫情爆发以来，这是我们听到最多的一种，也就是所谓的“西班牙流感”。我们知道，西班牙流感
if there's two different viruses, two different strains in the same cell, the parts, the mix and match parts can get put together in a different fashion. So it evolves in this way that it can make it very elusive. So we still obviously are always trying to kind of predict and keep up with which strain of the flu is going to emerge this year. The history of flu is very interesting because the 1918 flu is not the first big flu pandemic in history. So this is a disease that must repeatedly have moved out of bird populations into humans and cause waves of respiratory disease. So there's one in the 1890s, isn't there? There's a big one in 1890 to 92, sometimes called the Russian flu. And so people have compared that to COVID.
在盟军的大型军营里就已经存在了，有一种说法认为它可能源自美国中西部，是由——我的意思是，据我所知，关于这一点目前尚无定论，但也许你更清楚？你认为——西班牙流感能给我们带来什么其他的教训？1918-1919年的情况与2020-2021年之间，是否存在某些特别能够产生共鸣的相似之处？还是说你认为它们完全不同？嗯，作为一个优秀的学者，我的回答会是“既是也不是”。当然，目前还没有定论。我认为，我们并不真正知道它起源于美国中西部。更好、更新的研究表明，当它真正显现出来时，它已经是无处不在了。我们并不——它是一种病毒，一种其病毒通常在鸟类种群中呈地方性流行的病毒。这是少数几种哺乳动物疾病中比较罕见的一种。这是一种鸟类疾病，虽然说不上绝无仅有，但它确实有点奇特。流感的进化方式与新冠肺炎非常不同。它有一个分段的基因组。它的基因组有点像由这八个可以混合搭配的部分组成的。这就是所谓的H1N1，它们编码不同的蛋白质。当病毒基因组进入宿主细胞并重新组装时，
Well, even more than that, some people have wondered, sit back a little bit here, there are, including COVID-19, there are seven coronaviruses that infect humans from this family, seven different species. Four of them before COVID-19 are already everywhere. We've all probably had a couple of them. They cause little common colds. We can estimate how old these viruses are. And an older paper about 15 years ago, using the viral genome, said that one of the main causes of the common cold in human this species of coronavirus emerged around 1890 and so this sometimes has caused people to wonder could the russian flu because we don't have the the dna or rna i should say of the
如果在同一个细胞中存在两种不同的病毒、两种不同的毒株，这些可混合搭配的部分就可以以不同的方式组合在一起。因此它以这种方式进化，使其变得非常难以捉摸。所以我们显然仍在不断试图预测并跟上今年将要出现的流感毒株。流感的历史非常有趣，因为1918年的流感并不是历史上的第一次大型流感大流行。所以这是一种必然会反复从鸟类种群转移到人类身上并引发呼吸道疾病浪潮的疾病。1890年代也有过一次流感，对吧？在1890到1892年之间有过一次非常大的流感，有时被称为俄国流感。因此人们将其与新冠进行了比较。
the russian flu um so we don't actually know what caused it. And so people have said, could this have been actually the emergence event of this now common cold coronavirus? I think it's a really interesting question. And we would like hard data in the form of the RNA of the virus from lung tissue of a victim, which surely exists in a museum collection somewhere. They got measles from like 1911 from a lung preserved in formaldehyde. So somebody somewhere should be able to just solve this question. But I think the Russian flu is probably flu.
不仅如此，有些人甚至在想——稍微退一步讲——包括新冠肺炎在内，这个家族中有七种感染人类的冠状病毒，七种不同的物种。在新冠肺炎之前，其中的四种就已经无处不在了。我们大概都感染过其中的几种。我们可以估算出这些病毒的年代。大约15年前的一篇论文利用病毒基因组指出，人类普通感冒的主要病因之一——这种冠状病毒物种——大约在1890年左右出现。这有时会让人们产生疑问：俄国流感会不会就是——因为我们没有俄国流感的DNA或RNA，应该这么说——
In 1918 though, this influenza pandemic explodes. And it's true, it's a really extraordinary event. In some ways, it's the, it's the ultimate expression of a globalized world without yet jet travel. So it's still steamship and railroads that are, that are spreading it over long distances. But it is this, it's the ultimate pandemic in the age of fossil fuel transportation. And its global impact is enormous, 50 to 100 million dead. They didn't have the same therapeutics or clinical care that we have today. is that the 1918 flu disproportionately affects healthy people in their late childhood to early adulthood. And the demographic and social and economic impact of that is very different from COVID-19, but also just the moral political dimensions of this. So I think, I don't think
所以我们实际上并不知道是什么引发了俄国流感。因此有人说，这会不会实际上就是现在这种常见感冒冠状病毒的爆发事件呢？我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题。我们希望获得确凿的数据，比如从某个博物馆馆藏中某位死者的肺部组织中提取出该病毒的RNA，这样的组织肯定存在于某个地方。他们曾从1911年保存在福尔马林中的肺部组织中提取过麻风病病毒。所以某处的某个人应该能够解开这个谜题。但我认为俄国流感可能就是流感。
this is right, by the way, but I'm just saying it as a descriptive fact. I think if COVID-19 really, really made a lot of kids sick, that the whole moral political response to it would be different. I think parents would just say, screw it, you're all getting vaccinated and wearing masks, or you're not going to be in public ever again. So that takes us back to the passage that I read right at the beginning of our kind of tour de raison of history and disease, where you say that, I'll read it again, that dying of infectious disease had become anomalous, virtually scandalous in the developed world. That is clearly a part of the impact that COVID has had, isn't it? It is felt as a kind of scandal it's a it's a moral scandal that anyone should die of it uh but it's also a kind of scandal in in that this
然而在1918年，这场流感大流行爆发了。确实，这是一场非常非凡的事件。在某种程度上，它是没有喷气式旅行的全球化世界的终极体现。因此，当时传播它的仍然是汽船和铁路，将它带到长途各地。但它是化石燃料交通时代终极的大流行病。其全球影响是巨大的，造成5000万至1亿人死亡。当时他们没有我们今天拥有的同等疗法或临床护理。是1918年的流感不成比例地影响了从儿童后期到成年早期的健康人群。其人口、社会和经济影响与新冠肺炎截然不同，同时这也体现在道德和政治维度上。所以我想——顺便说一句，我认为这并不对，我只是把它作为一个描述性的事实来说。我想如果新冠肺炎真的让很多孩子生病的话，针对它的整个道德政治反应就会完全不同。我想父母们会直接说：“去他的，你们所有人都要去打疫苗、戴口罩，否则休想再踏出公共场所半步。”这就把我们带回了我在这趟历史与疾病之旅的一开始所读的那段话，你当时说——我再读一遍——在发达国家，死于传染病已经变得不正常，甚至几乎是一种耻辱。这显然是新冠疫情所产生的影响的一部分，对吧？人们觉得这是一种耻辱，任何人死于此病都是一种道德上的耻辱，但同时这也是一种耻辱，因为这
shouldn't be happening to us we've it's a stage of history that we yeah it offends our sense of progress doesn't it you know we've moved on from there yeah exactly and that's one of the big differences in from the 1918 morally and politically that was a society even in places like britain and the united states where they still lived in a world where everyone alive you know was was more exposed to the burden of infectious disease and they remembered a very very recently receding world where it was just such a part of life whereas we've now had several generations where we just don't expect an infectious disease to cause a plague. I mean, a plague sounds like medieval. Don't these viruses know who we are?
这本不应该发生在我们身上，我们正处于历史的一个阶段……是的，这冒犯了我们的进步观念，对吧？你知道的，我们已经走过了那个阶段。是的，完全如此。这是1918年以来最大的不同之一。无论是从道德上还是政治上，当时的一个社会——甚至在英国和美国这样仍然生活在一个世界里的地方，活着的人都更加暴露于传染病的负担之下，他们记得一个不久前刚刚退去的由传染病构成的世界，传染病曾是生活如此密不可分的一部分——而我们现在已经经历了好几代人，不再期望传染病会引发一场瘟疫。我的意思是，瘟疫听起来就像中世纪的词汇。难道这些病毒不知道我们是谁吗？
So one of the things that people have actually said about COVID is that it's an effect of globalization. I mean, that's clearly the case that flights and everything. But clearly, one of the lessons of what you've been saying is that globalization has always been bad for health, that people moving around the world, it's right from the very beginning. But doesn't it go, isn't it bigger than globalization, Tom? Isn't it? I mean, maybe I'm putting words in your mouth now, Carl, so feel free to tell me I'm talking absolute rubbish. But isn't it that civilization? Well, that was the second.
因此，人们对新冠病毒实际说过的一点是，它是全球化的一个结果。我的意思是，航班和一切显然就是这样。但很显然，你所说的话带来的教训之一是，全球化对健康一直都是有害的，人们在世界各地四处流动，从最开始就是这样。但是，汤姆，这难道不是超越了全球化吗？难道不是吗？我的意思是，卡尔，也许我现在是在替你发言，所以如果你觉得我在胡说八道，请尽管告诉我。但这难道不是文明的问题吗？嗯，那是第二点。
The other lesson is that you basically you can't have a civilizational advance without a pathogenic advance as well. Yeah. And again, we may not want to hear this or believe this because we want simple narratives and we want to believe we can progress and succeed, but look at it like an ecologist. Remember that we're animals that have parasites that want to take advantage of our success. If there are more of us,
另一个教训是，基本上，你不可能在没有致病原推进的同时取得文明的进步。是的。而且同样地，我们可能不想听到或相信这一点，因为我们想要简单的叙事，我们想要相信我们能够进步和成功，但试着像生态学家一样看待它。记住，我们是那些拥有想要利用我们成功的寄生虫的动物。如果有更多的人口，
there are more cells to invade and to rob and to exploit and to hijack. And so look at it from an ecologist perspective and that contradiction, that paradox kind of dissolves. Anytime there is technology that lets us be more populous and more interconnected, it's going to change the zone of opportunity, the calculus for a pathogen and motivate them to try and take advantage of us in new ways. And so, yes, technological progress is good. It creates energy and alleviates poverty, suffering and early death. It also helps stir the evolution of new diseases. Globalization is good. It brings us the ideas and human diversity and of course the cuisine of the world. It's a great thing with
就会有更多的细胞可供入侵、掠夺、剥削和劫持。因此，从生态学的角度来看待它，那种矛盾、那种悖论某种程度上就化解了。任何能够让我们变得更加繁盛和更加紧密相连的技术，都会改变病原体的机遇区和计算方式，并促使它们以新的方式试图利用我们。所以，是的，技术进步是好的。它创造了能量，减轻了贫困、痛苦和早逝。它也有助于推动新疾病的演变。全球化是好的。它给我们带来了思想、人类的多样性，当然还有世界各地的美食。这是一件了不起的事情，具有
tremendous material and spiritual advantages and there's no going back. So we couldn't and we shouldn't undo globalization, but that doesn't change. And this is why I say we may not want to believe this, but the reality is that also exposes us to diseases in different ways. And so we just have to confront that from a realistic perspective rather than one that's kind of rooted in what we wish were the way the world works.
巨大的物质和精神优势，而且已经无法回头。所以我们过去不能、现在也不应该取消全球化，但这并没有改变这一点。这就是为什么我说我们可能不愿意相信这一点，但现实是它也以不同的方式让我们暴露在疾病之中。因此，我们必须从现实的角度来面对这一点，而不是从那种植根于我们希望世界如何运转的愿望的角度去面对。
That seems the perfect point of which trend, doesn't it, Tom? Kyle, what an amazing sort of panoramic account your book is um thank you and thank you so much for coming on the podcast and taking us through it i mean it's actually quite a depressing story in a way but i suppose it's it's good to well it doesn't need to be depressing does it because it's just facing up to our own humanity and our place in the world well they also i mean you know you you read plagues upon the earth disease in the course of human history um you read it and you feel even with what we've gone through the past two years how lucky we are to be like i mean it's like it's like that people always say dentistry don't they when they say you know what period of life would
汤姆，这似乎是一个完美的切入点，不是吗？卡尔，你的书真是一部令人惊叹的全景式著作，嗯，谢谢你，非常感谢你来到播客并带我们了解它。我的意思是，从某种程度上讲，这其实是一个相当令人沮丧的故事，但我想这很好……嗯，它其实不一定令人沮丧，对吧？因为这只是正视我们自己的复杂人性以及我们在世界上的地位。嗯，而且我还想说，你知道，你读《大地的瘟疫：人类历史进程中的疾病》，嗯，读完之后，即使考虑到我们过去两年所经历的一切，你也会觉得自己有多么幸运，能像……我的意思是，这就像人们总是说的牙科学一样，对吧？当他们说，你知道，你会选择历史上的哪个时期……
you what period of history would you like to live in people are the present because of dentistry but you definitely you know you read your book and you think we we we are lucky to be born when we are and i can't emphasize enough um that this is a brilliant work of history but it's also stylistically brilliant it's wonderfully well written thank you and indeed um the incredible book that you wrote on slavery and on um christian sex morality in late antiquity very different fields. So Tom definitely has your picture by his side. Well, it's mutual. Well, do you know, I mean, I think your books on late antiquity, I think you're the heir of Peter Brown,
你愿意生活在历史的哪个时期？人们会选当下，因为有了牙科。但你绝对会，你知道，读了你的书，你会觉得我们生在当今这个时代是多么幸运，我怎么强调都不为过，嗯，这是一部杰出的历史著作，而且在文风上也极其出色，写得非常精彩。谢谢你。的确，嗯，你关于奴隶制以及晚期古代基督教性道德的那些不可思议的著作，那是完全不同的领域。所以汤姆肯定把你的照片放在他身边。嗯，这是相互的。嗯，你知道吗，我的意思是，我觉得你关于晚期古代的著作，我觉得你是彼得·布朗的传人，
and there is no higher praise that can be given. There is none, but that's too kind. Thank you all. This was a lot of fun. I'm very touched by your kind words and and thoughtful readership of the book and um it is a little a little depressing but there are some there's some optimistic and hopeful elements too so um we can we'll we'll pull through this eventually it hasn't been pretty and it won't be but um but i'm an optimist in the long run okay thanks so much
再也没有比这更高的赞誉了。确实没有，但这也太谬赞了。谢谢大家。这非常有趣。我深受感动，感谢你们的美言以及对这本书的深入阅读，嗯，这确实有点令人沮丧，但也有一些乐观和充满希望的元素，所以，嗯，我们最终会挺过去这一关的。虽然过程并不美好，未来也不会轻松，但从长远来看，我是一个乐观主义者。好的，非常感谢。
thank you all thanks so much for listening um We'll see you next week. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
谢谢大家，非常感谢大家的收听，我们下周见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告体验以及我们的聊天社区权限，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。再次强调，是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及精彩的娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。